if you like gods are asking yourselves
well what the hell do you do Nell well
the answer is to sit back there witness
to the end of your journey and just do
it subscribe to the new order view for
regular anime manga content uploaded
straight into YouTube feed which by and
large I guarantee will be more of a
happy thing than not hello and welcome
to the new world review your source for
everything anime and manga and today we
have an exciting development it goes
after quite a thorough eternity which I
guess they mean about three-quarters of
year we have a new berserk chapter being
360 and to celebrate we are going to go
ahead and review it right here because
that's the sort of thing that we do
sometimes and to kick things off this
chapter is entitled cherry tree garden
and it was pretty chill as I think was
to be expected given where things left
off we are still currently residing
within the greatest paradise ever
showcased within this hellish series and
the bulk of this installment focuses on
shake-a and fantasy mostly you know
showing off some of those skills to pay
the bills but also just delving into
some nice exploration of magic in
general now we'll get into that but I
find it very difficult to dive into that
side of the chapter when by far the most
standout thing to me was obviously those
last few pages with guts and the skull
Knight and as we were drawing close to
the end of the chapter I was starting to
wonder if we'd see anything from guts at
all and then when he appeared just
swinging his blade endlessly training he
kind of dawned on me even before he said
the words but you know exactly what does
guts do now in regards to his mission
for the large majority of the series it
is fairly complete he was able to
protect in faerie Kostka to the point
where her sanity was restored and there
really isn't anything more he can do to
help that whole situation
in fact by just being around Casca at
the moment guts is actively making
things worse which is another piece of
classic berserk II and tragedy but then
of course mr. skull Knight just rocks up
as he often does and caps off the
chapter by saying that guts is to simply
bear witness to the end of his journey
and that that is not always a happy
thing which I thought was a perfect end
of the chapter and that line had a
massive impact on me in several
different ways
so one way you could think about things
would be a huge sigh of relief since
we've been struggling well I mean as
readers some of you have quite
potentially been struggling for almost
three decades now it certainly hasn't
been quite that long for me but well
over a decade and to hear that at the
very least this cast Commission portion
of the story has come to completion is a
pretty mammoth thing and very relieving
and on the other hand it's also
incredibly bittersweet because obviously
things have not turned out as many of us
would have hoped
but I think it's more or less how we
expected things to play out ever since
the initial warning about guts as
desires not necessarily matching those
of Casca in fact in some cases things
may have played out even better than
many of us expected but then to compound
that there is also a legitimate sense of
what is this berserk coming to an actual
end here I mean obviously not right here
and now which I need to make clear but
is this signaling the beginning of the
end for berserk and personally I don't
necessarily think so for an abundance of
reasons but that is the kind of gravity
that the words of the skull Knight
possess in this moment and I think it's
pretty amazing that some very simple
words of dialogue can hold such power
but as for why berserk is very unlikely
to be ending anytime soon well you need
look no further than the rest of the
chapter because every character who is
in cuts still has ongoing threats
Casca is obviously entering a new more
conscious phase of her quest to reform
the shoud itself chikai and fauna say
have at the very least some new magical
quests but the farmer says in particular
being connected to kaskus thread even
Serpico remains unresolved because you
only see the tiniest bit of him in this
chapter but Mira does make a point to
have him appear and say that he is
conflicted which is a very strong sign
that he still has more growth to undergo
and not to mention the comparatively
newer additions to the party like
Magnifico or Roderick who at the very
least seemed to exist for maybe some
great a narrative purpose and they have
currently served as well as the newer
characters who have been introduced in
elf film and I guess I'm specifically
referring to Mordor who was being set up
as like an actual character here as
opposed to many of the other coven
members who are just miscellaneous
students and masters and whatever Mordor
though she is a very unique presence and
even in this chapter there are constant
panels cutting back to her reactions and
I just had this sense of why bother
setting her up to be something if
berserk is indeed ending sometime soon
but all of that is mostly technical
narrative speculation in reality Mura
can do whatever he wants and if berserk
were to end in a state like this and hey
you know what it's probably the closest
possible thing that we would have to a
happy ending for this series and yes
there is also the whole Griffith thing
as always which I'm very interested in
actually because the thing I always need
to remember is the idea that time and
LFL moves fast slower than the outer
realms so depending on how long we end
up spending here who knows how the world
would have changed if and when the
characters do eventually leave I mean I
don't think it would be an absolutely
ungodly amount of time because I'm not
entirely sure how long puck has been
away from my thumb but I do remember one
of the residents stating that they
didn't even notice he was gone while
others said it had been a while so it
likely wasn't a huge amount of time
I'm thinking that at most by the time
they leave here a few decades might have
passed rather than like hundreds of
years although that would also be very
very cool but one of the most exciting
prospects of the former idea holds would
be getting to meet an adult Rickett
because that boy is surely going to grow
into an absolute boss but the world in
general is going to be a very very
different place and if anything I
suppose that would be the setup for
perhaps one final long arc to bring this
series to a conclusion in any case
that's getting quite a bit beyond the
scope of this particular chapter but
those last few pages were pretty
phenomenal and quite understated for
what they are cutting back to the
beginning now though the first few pages
with Casco were also quite nice given
how still unfamiliar we are with her
original self it very much feels like a
rare and treasured occasion just to have
her speak a coherent sentence albeit
exceptionally painful given the stage
needs to be introducer and quite
probably my favorite moment of the Cosco
section was when she was whisked away to
sleep and was still holding furnaces
clerk rather tightly it was this really
nice visual cue of the relationship that
these two have formed and at the same
time it's so conflicting because while
Casca might trust varnas a completely
bond essays feelings on the matter are
much more complicated because she's
obviously smitten over mr. guts and
actually very much has her moments of
resentment towards carska for being the
target of his affections but at the same
time she's also not genuinely upset with
Casca it's more the situation that gets
to her and there is also this very just
pure connection between Casca and
fantasy it seems like a twisted play on
the whole bestfriends liking the same
person idea which can be really cringe
in a lot of media but I think it's
handled very well in berserk and yeah I
guess I just love the fact that such a
simple action of Casca tugging on Fontes
cloak can evoke and portray this entire
complicated relationship that the two of
them have it's a beautiful example of
Mirrors talent in the realm of micro
writing and constructing specific
moments but while we're on this train
there's a lot more to delve into with
fine assay as she is actually arguably
the main focus of the chapter and
immediately after this denying gives her
some brand-new garbs the world not new
new Tufano circus and just like that she
has a new outfit and I think that it
looks pretty great I especially love the
Hat it suits us so so well you think it
frames her hair very nicely and weird
tangent about hair here that was always
kind of annoyed when far as they cut her
hair because I preferred her original
design I did of course enjoy the
symbolic nature of what she was doing
but the character never quite looked the
same to me again but here with an
accompanying
hat she feels aesthetically complete all
of a sudden so huzzah for that that is
of course just a strange me thing but
more importantly finally it gets to show
off her skills in this chapter which go
on to shock all of the other which links
because gasp fauna sake can perform
magic without the use of a circle
because you know circles are for
amateurs really but this demonstration
has also brought up something that
frequently pops into my mind which is
how long fauna say has been actively
studying magic for and the answer given
here is about three months which is
absolute madness I know that reading
this manga with the actual release
schedule it feels like fauna say has
very very gradually progressed with
magic but anytime I reread berserk it
always hits me just how abnormally
quickly find a say picked all of this up
and even in this chapter you have one of
the students going on man it took me
three years to do that thing that she
did in three months and I think that
with that we can officially acknowledge
that her character has discovered an
innate natural talent which is huge
because she has spent most of the series
with a crippling sense of inferiority
and not actually being good at anything
except for taking care of Casca and even
though she did have a decent perceived
talent for magic that was always
secondary to the power of she okay
so it never seems like that much of a
big deal it was more like fauna say was
just like budget shaky however given
that we have a solid sense of what fauna
say has achieved in a mere three months
I honestly don't think it's out of the
question to posit the idea that she
actually possesses far more raw talent
than she okay and with a couple of years
of dedicated study she could be a true
force to be reckoned with and that's
particularly impressive given a
statement from she okay that always
stuck with me when she said something
along the lines of not being able to
pick up the art if you can remember a
time when you were not studying it so
good on fauna say although the
inferiority complex is still alive and
well as demonstrated when she said that
she was not worthy of the clothes that
she had been adorned with oh well she
still continues to grow and evolve and
honestly be one of the most fascinating
characters in all of berserk and without
we sure so Delft properly into she K as
well who also gets to show off by
summoning a particular darkness demon
who was actually portrayed really nicely
with this like funky splotchy technique
a very cool texture from the absolute
master of manga texture here once again
she also manages to achieve this without
magic circles and even goes on to
explain that on their journey there was
never any time to construct such fancy
technical implements due to extreme and
repetitive danger basically what she
okay is stating here is that
that pressure creates diamonds also more
commonly known as single swim which does
also explain fauna says incredible
growth because she was put in a position
where it was either learn the stuff or
potentially die the latter of which is
generally unappealing to say the least
although this whole idea of circles is
very much reminding me if Full Metal
Alchemist
you know given how everyone was always
shocked when Edward could perform
alchemy without a circle but getting
back to berserk it looks like Chaka has
been given an intriguing offer to
communicate with beings of a deeper
realm including that of her former
mistress so that is a very funky thread
being laid down here as this little
witch continues on her incidental
journey to become quite possibly one of
the most powerful humans in existence
but to conclude after almost a year of
hiatus I can very much understand if
this chapter wasn't everything that
everyone would have been hoping for it
was a very long wait for what was in
essence a very light chapter speckled
with wonderful character moments as well
as a pretty damn solid and powerful
ending personally I absolutely enjoyed
it although I am just grateful any time
there is new berserk to consume no
matter what the chapter tackles and this
is no exception it had plenty to both
sustain my interest as bolas piqued my
intrigue for more although as for when
the next chapter will grace us all I
know is that apparently there was an
announcement in the magazine the berserk
would not be in the next issue so we are
looking at two months at the very least
sad news as always but I feel like most
of the struggle is he used to it by now
and it's something that we can easily
live with what do you guys think please
do leave your thoughts on the chapter in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you came for some
more anime manga content and please do
go and check out some of my other videos
we'll even subscribe to the channel for
more potential berserk goodness to live
it straight into your YouTube feed but
for now this has been the new world view
and I'll see you next time